knowing you now for a couple of years
I went on it so let me see who JB's wife
is well that is a good looking woman do
you talk about your romance how did you
get her where did you meet her I mean
here's what it is when I met my wife I
was a cordial cordial gentleman you know
I was at a restaurant called Jared I was
sitting at a table two other comedians
we were just hanging out after a show I
see these ladies standing on it was a
long line and getting you know and I
knew the the owner of the restaurant and
[ __ ] you know we we're there all the
time after we do our comedy shows and
then we're just sitting there and this
beautiful lady walks through the
restaurant to go to the restroom oh my
gosh it was just her hair was bouncing
you know the world slowed the [ __ ] down
a little bit Howard sometimes that
happens was it Love at First Sight JB
when you saw her I can't say that but I
was intrigued I was [ __ ] intrigued
she walked me I said hello I said hello
and she said nothing [ __ ] nothing oh
she knows you we were hitting on her and
she wasn't interested
time all the time now how do I as a
[ __ ] uh as a man break through that
right on the Hawaii on the whole way
back I said look listen I see you ladies
standing out there this is The Cordial
[ __ ] gentleman of me I say see like
standing online no lady should be
standing online I hit her with that [ __ ]
right right I saw a swallow she said she
felt that [ __ ] when I said no lady
should be standing online got beautiful
heels on right now you shouldn't be
standing online like that you know I
know the guy at the at the who owns the
restaurant I'm gonna get you guys to
seat right she walked away I don't think
she believed me I caught my guy over I
said hey man look this beautiful lady is
right there there's three of them you
know it's the table right here next to
us wide open I know people online but
[ __ ] them but [ __ ] them a seat right
here you know I'm trying to make a move
on on the on the on the show in other
words you were honest with the guy you
said to him listen I'm trying to hit on
this girl you'd make me a hero if you
marched her over right right
I have to find more about her and then
they know he brings them over to our
table and they sit next to us
I see ladies and enjoy yourselves you
know I want to make sure you guys had a
seat and she was impressed with that
move to that power move that's a power
move power move okay and then they sat
down and here's the key to this [ __ ] to
all you fellas out there who don't know
how to [ __ ] act I ignored her the
whole [ __ ] time
I didn't feel like I didn't expect
anything from her sandwiches [ __ ]
seat talk to me oh I got you a seat give
me your number I said zero I checked
them one time I said when their food
came and they started eating their food
I said everything okay she said yes
thank you so much I said enjoy your meal
you are a genius now look they're
packing up to leave right right and and
we're we're about to leave and then all
of a sudden we said she stood up with or
they all three stood up and she said
thank you so much for you know assisting
getting us a seat I said oh anytime you
know you ladies are beautiful so I'm
happy you guys had a great time now
here's where I kind of said here's where
I jumped on the ass I said so uh oh a
quick question um where are we gonna go
on our first date that's what I said too
I like that
that's not too aggressive are we going
on oh are we going to go out I said I
hope so you know we exchanged
information right she goes outside gives
the ballet her ticket right and then I I
go outside they're still just about to
get their car the car pulls up they walk
they get in the car right I can see her
through the windshield so I gave it a
little wave goodbye you know what I mean
and then she I saw her this is the move
that got me hooked on her Howard she
looked she's parked against the curb and
gave her the [ __ ] keys to the car she
gets in the car she starts the car up
she [ __ ] looks both ways and
proceeded to do the most vicious illegal
[ __ ] U-turn I've ever seen in my
goddamn life
she damn near did a donut she did a half
a [ __ ] donut I said God damn you see
that [ __ ] that's the kind of woman I
love you know I mean aggressive in the
behind the wheel